[Musique]
aujourd'hui à l'émission les beaux
paysages souvent façonné par
l'agriculture ont une valeur mais au
québec on peine à la définir
alors qu'en france on aménage des
territoires pour conserver leur beauté
en suisse on subventionne les
agriculteurs pour entretenir le paysage
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte
depuis des milliers d'années les
activités agricoles fabrique des
paysages souvent d'une grande beauté
cette beauté là on la ressent on la
recherche aussi on est même prêt à payer
plus pour une maison avec une jolie vue
en campagne par exemple
mais si certains pays d'europe valoriser
même finances l'entretien des beaux
paysages agricoles
ici au québec on a encore beaucoup de
chemin à faire il ya des territoires au
québec qui se développe très rapidement
un peu n'importe comment
c'est que le territoire est souvent
laissées en bateau sur un peu réac à qui
le possède
il ya une question d'harmonisation une
question de qualité de vie
le paysage est un bien collectif
[Musique]
si ce paysage est beau si les gens du
plaisir de venir chez nous c'est grâce
aux paysans qui nous ont forgé ce
paysage
[Musique]
le paysage chez nous qu'ils fassent au
nord on façonne par nos pratiques nos
achats aux déplacements et donc ce n'est
que le reflet de nos mains
c'est assurément un des très bons
chemins au québec
depuis de nombreuses décennies gerald de
dôme on étudie l'évolution du paysage et
du territoire au québec on voit avec la
topographie ça aide beaucoup d'avoir un
accès visuel hudak et comme c'était très
cultivé à l'époque une percée visuelle
était très très nombreuses et très
variée mais bon ça change et la
fraîcheur repris lé frère repris il ya
des nouveaux arrivants qui sont
implantés qui pourraient avoir leur
calme
on me les clôtures ont mis des brise
vent ont mis des haies de cèdres tous
est fermé
donc c'est un peu l'histoire des routes
c'est un peu l'histoire s'est résumée à
une évolution de l'agriculture et la
perte de certains paysages quelqu'un
couture façonnés au québec comme partout
l'agriculture fabrique les paysages
fabrique ce que l'on voit
mais quand l'agriculture change le
paysage change lui aussi jusque dans les
moindres détails
tu t'en vas juste un exemple et les
clôtures
oui et tu les plus coûteux alors
qu'auparavant des cultures de perdre est
partout
ce paysage de il restait agricole mais
il n'a rien à voir avec un paysage que
vous alliez rencontrer dans les années
40-50 même 60
comprendre l'évolution d'un territoire
c'est comprendre un jeu complexe un
rapport de force très très complexes
entre eux les conditions naturelles donc
le climat
le relief qui pourront adapter à
différents types d'agriculture
les types de sols nos politiques
agricoles et jusqu'à aujourd'hui
l'évolution des marchés mondiaux aussi
qu'ils vont jouer sur l' influence de
nos territoires
au québec on repère deux grandes phases
de transformation du territoire agricole
la première elle va s'étendre vers les
50 jusqu'aux années 80 puis la deuxième
des années 80 à aujourd'hui
on
en 1950 environ le quart de la
population québécoise vit de
l'agriculture la production laitière et
rennes en 1950 on estime qu'à peu près
60 70 % des fermes sont des fermes
laitières
les vaches sont l extérieur en pâturages
et les fermes ont plusieurs bâtiments y
avait beaucoup de bâtiments qui est très
très rapprochés et qui donnait chacun
sur une surface rectangulaire qui est
inculte huées et donc les chantait
beaucoup d'outils et pas les propriétés
étaient beaucoup plus petit
à cette époque le territoire agricole
occupe une large part des zones habitées
que ce soit dans les basses terres du
saint laurent comme en montérégie déjà
fortement agricole ou dans les régions
périphériques dans les plateaux
laurentides hien ou appalachiennes là on
a une agriculture qui a une génération
qui vient juste de défricheur territoire
c'est quand même des territoires qui
sont très difficiles à cultiver
on va avec ça on va nourrir la famille
tout cela va changer et très rapidement
durant les décennies 60 70
alors que l'agriculture se modernise
s'industrialise la productivité agricole
et la taille des fermes augmente mais le
nombre de fermes diminue entre 1950 et
1980 on perd à peu près 7,9 ferme par
jour au québec
chaque jour qui passe 7.9 fermes
disparaissent
parallèlement l'étalement urbain prend
de l'ampleur les meilleures terres
agricoles sont menacés et pression
urbaine était telle qu'on voyait en fait
les meilleures terres agricoles du
québec notamment au couteau à montréal
disparaître sur l'urbanisation avec
d'excellentes terres qui étaient aux
friches sous spéculation pression qu'on
attendait de pouvoir développer ce
territoire là pour s'attaquer à ce
problème le gouvernement du québec vote
en 1978 la loi sur la protection du
territoire agricole dégage à la même
époque
les gouvernements fédéral et provincial
met en place la gestion de l'offre des
politiques de stabilisation du revenu
ainsi que l'assurance récolte ce sont
des mesures qui auront aussi un effet
sur le territoire agricole
si entre 1950 et 1980 on a perdu
beaucoup de territoires agricoles
nos pères de territoires agricoles elles
font beaucoup plus faible à partir des
années 80 donc nos politiques agricoles
elles ont quand même permis de
stabiliser et de réduire ses pertes de
territoire agricole
depuis les années 80 le territoire
agricole dans les basses terres du saint
laurent s'est maintenue et ce malgré les
pressions du développement urbain mais
le paysage agricole de ces régions a
changé avec la chute du nombre de fermes
il y a moins de bâtiments dans le
paysage la modernisation des techniques
de production fait aussi entrer les
animaux dans les bâtiments fini les
beaux pâturages et les fermes qui
restent sont désormais grosse avec des
parcelles plus grande en 1967 de 55000
ferme et fière aujourd'hui un récent
25000 donc ça vous donne une idée de la
vitesse de transformation et de la
concentration
l'industrie porcine connaît elle aussi
un boom de développement modifiant du
coup paysage et culture en montérégie
par exemple dans les années 50 ces
grands champs étaient occupés à 60 70 %
par la production de fourrage
aujourd'hui sur ces même superficie le
maïs grain et le soya ont remplacé les
culture du foin dans les régions en
périphérie des basses terres du saint
laurent
la disparition des fermes et du
territoire agricole est préoccupante
on est dans un paysage qui s'est
extrêmement transformé au cours des 60
80 dernières années
on parle ici d'un paysage qui était à
peu près à 60% cultivées dans les années
aujourd'hui il va rester à peu près 10%
d'agriculture de ce qu'ils avaient à
l'époque il ya un resserrement de
l'agriculture au lieu de monter de la
friche donc c'est sûr que quand les
friches mais on risque d'avoir moins
d'attrait en risque de perdre sa paie
ses particularités en puriste de perdre
son attractivité
[Musique]
depuis les dernières décennies au québec
la loi sur la protection du territoire
agricole a permis de protéger des
superficies pour l'agriculture mais on
n'a pas protégé l'agriculture comme
activité sur ces territoires
dans beaucoup de régions quand on parle
du développement on parle du
développement urbain ou du développement
d'autres activités économiques que
l'agriculture ce territoire agricole ça
va être vu comme un espace à développer
et non pas un espace à protéger et à
développer pour l'agriculture donc il ya
aussi tout ce rapport là et cette
redécouverte de l'agriculture qu'il faut
faire aussi sur nos territoires
[Musique]
ce que vit le québec n'est pas unique la
modernisation et la mondialisation de
l'agriculture ainsi que l'urbanisation
ont modifié notre territoire et nos
paysages et cela risque de s'accélérer
dans les années à venir
le paysan généreux faire de nos
politiques d'un dogue relation au
territoire et c'est simplement
l'expression
si une accentuation ou nette
intensification des usages
le paysage se transforme si demain matin
on se met importer du lait c'est sûr que
si on change quelque chose d'aussi
important que les quotas laitiers ses
succès une répercussion immédiate sur le
paysage
il faut je pense se faire à l'idée que
ça va évoluer comme ça toujours évolué
la question c est qu en pause ce jour
c'est vers quoi on veut que ça évolue
[Musique]
après la pause caractériser les paysages
pour mieux les aménager
[Musique]
c'est emblématique c'est le rocher percé
du sud du québec
[Musique]
l'image appartient à tous tous donc on
n'est pas prêt à vous et moi on est
propriétaire de ça mais ça dépend
effectivement de d'activité le
propriétaire du terrain
[Musique]
des gens s'arrêtent le voit et on voit
que cherche la fnath pour trouver
l'endroit à partir duquel prendre une
photo et puis c'est devenu de plus en
plus restreint
si l'on peut bien voir l'abbaye de
saint-benoît-du-lac et les collines
environnantes
c'est en grande partie grâce à
l'agriculture à quelques pas d'ici
lowy a pas eu d'animaux pour ne pas
faire de coupes de bois si c'est
incroyable la rapidité avec laquelle les
paysages se refaire je prends de
l'intérêt nécessairement des ressources
financières éventuellement parce que si
on n'a pas de projet d'agriculture
parce qu'on nous prend la relève parce
que la police ou parce qu'on a pas
l'intérêt qui le fait le problème c'est
qu'au québec la notion de paysage ne
fait pas partie des plans d'aménagement
des différentes municipalités les
paysages ne sont pas gérées comme un
bien commun le territoire d'abord perçue
comme une ressource une ressource
agricole ou une ressource forestière
ressources hydrauliques etc
le territoire le paysage est façonné bon
parcours différents ministères réussir
l'agriculture ce que l'agriculture
hydro-québec ce que de transmettre de
l'énergie
le mtq s'occupe du transport mais y'a
personne qui s'occupe de tout seul
les paysages évolue donc augurer des
volontés des propriétaires terriens
qu'il soit gouvernementaux ou privés le
territoire est souvent laissé en pâture
un peu à qui le possède
en restant dans la réglementation qui
existe évidemment restant dans les
limites dans les balises de la loi ou
des règlements on peut faire à peu près
ce qu'on veut un endroit
[Musique]
mais dans plusieurs régions on veut que
ça change
il de verchères en plein milieu du saint
laurent une délégation des ménages east
et de représentants de la mrc marguerite
d'youville vont à la découverte de cet
archipel ont pu protéger de la ça
modifie beaucoup la conf louis philippe
roussel fait partie du groupe
il a pour mission de documenter ce qu'il
voit partout dans la mrc pour bâtir ce
que l'on appelle un atlas de paysages ça
c'est un gros ouvrage de caractérisation
des paysages qu'on cherche à connaître
chacun des paysages qui sont présents
sur la mrc on cherche à les qualifier
allez comprendre à comprendre comment il
évolue comme un commun existe on parle
de paysages agricoles le paysage
forestier de paysages aussi de milieux
humides
on parle du paysage fluvial des
archipels et on parle aussi dans
marguerite d'youville le paysage
suburbains ces atlas de paysages sont un
nouvel outil d'aménagement du territoire
l'idée vient d'europe ils ont pour but
de bien documenter le territoire
présents et passés de comprendre les
usages humains en lien avec la
géographie et l'écologie
il vise à aider les aménagistes et les
urbanistes à favoriser un meilleur
développement territorial c'est une
approche où on regarde d'où on vient
donc le paysage s'est constitué comme un
dalle pas assez
mieux on connaît notre paysage pu par la
suite on peut raffiner nos outils et
avoir une meilleure adhésion sur ce
qu'on veut faire en terme
d'interventions par la suite sur deux
territoires
c'est de dépasser le cadre du beau du
laid donc ne travaille pas pour espérer
faire du joli on travaille pour espérer
faire de l'harmonieux on n'est plus dans
la reconnaissance des qualités que des
potentiels des différents paysages pour
pouvoir mieux les planifier déplaçons
nous cette fois à rivière-ouelle au bas
saint laurent
[Musique]
ici on veut être les premiers à obtenir
une nouvelle désignation au québec celle
d'un paysage culturel patrimonial
le projet vise l'ensemble de ce que l'on
appelle la pointe aux orignaux
on arrive en fait ouais y'a vraiment des
caractéristiques particulières à la fois
géographique parce qu'il ya un cap
rocheux puis on voit tout le territoire
mais y'a mon historique du patrimoine
bâti et donc des vieilles maisons
ancestrales
il ya toute la notion de villégiature
donc les gens se sont installés au 19e
siècle il ya aussi la pêche à l'anguille
donc sa voix fin donc différents
éléments qui caractérisent un paysage
remarquable
[Musique]
nous autres on participe depuis 1769 ça
fait deux cent cinquante et un astéroïde
puis on a toujours fait stopper pas mal
de cette façon au yoyo une certaine
amélioration avec un thème et c'est oui
on fait partie du territoire ont fait
partie du patrimoine
ça donne rien changé quelque chose pour
changer pour de le moderniser j'aime
mieux ça reste comme celle à cette
désignation de paysage culturel
patrimonial n'apporte pas de budget
précis ni de protection intégrale c'est
avant tout une façon d'orienter le
développement
t'es pas obligé d'avoir des millions de
dollars pour faire des gestes au
quotidien et d'avoir collectivement une
vision de ce qu'on veut en termes de
développement paysages et de protection
de patrimoine bâti de cette intégration
tous ces éléments là sur un territoire
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec notre
agriculture nos pêche à l'anguille pas
la place par exemple de s'approprier
toutes les rives du fleuve construire
des maisons comme son et à laval ben il
ya une question d'harmonisation il ya
une question de qualité de vie et donc
ce cd gestes qui peuvent faire au niveau
réglementaire mais c'est le citoyen qui
doit aussi s'approprier et d'être
conscients de la valeur le paysage un
bien collectif
[Musique]
pour que le paysage devienne un
véritable bien collectif
[Musique]
il faudra développer une vision commune
sur la valeur et les enjeux de
développement qui affectent ses paysages
quand on regarde les gens s'implante
c'est pas aléatoire c'est notamment
profiter du paysage
notre paysage est une ressource
ressources à la fois comme carte de vie
à la fois pour le titre et touristique
c'est une ressource importante mais ce
n'est pas reconnu il n'y a pas de porter
de paysages au québec
[Musique]
en france en particulier gens sont
encore très proches de leurs territoires
sont proches de leur terroir son projet
hors produits locaux vous allez avoir
une multitude de lieux dits de deux
amours de village nommé ici ça prend
tout sur une route pour qu on annonce
qu'on traverse rameau même s'il a un mot
est là qui existe
[Musique]
il faut comprendre que l'agriculture ne
produit pas que des biens clos
alimentaire la forêt notre produit pas
que des deux parcs ap
ce sont des milieux qui produisent de
multiples choses et profiter des
paysages
toutes ces idées d'atlas ou de statut de
paysage culturel patrimonial marque peut
être le début d'une révolution dans la
compréhension et dans la gestion de
notre territoire
on voit de ces bêtes là mais c'est pas
juste ses propres principes justes du
boeuf s'est produit du paysage les gens
viennent apprécié et c'est ça qu'il faut
reconnaître dans cette espèce de
multifonctionnalité du territoire qu'on
on voit encore à travers des lots très
très spécifiques et décide ou très très
spéciaux
[Musique]
après la pause la france face aux défis
de l'évolution du territoire agricole
[Musique]
regardez un paysage c'est pénétrer dans
un pays c'est découvrir très rapidement
ses produits sur l'architecturé et
sigean pour bien des français on est ce
qu'on mange mais on pourrait aussi dire
qu'on est le lieu où on vit
[Musique]
plus mon espace est beau logiquement les
gens qui sont dedans se sentent bien et
c'est le reflet de ce qu'ils sont
la france est une mosaïque culturelle
historique et géographique tout le 6 km
à vous changer de paysage en france puis
un paysage et divers plus il peut
s'adapter à des crises
[Musique]
la france en fait toute l'europe et
beaucoup d'autres pays leur paysage
d'aujourd'hui sont l'héritage
d'activités humaines passées sur un
territoire qui a une histoire géologique
une histoire climatique yves michelin a
fait carrière en étudiant l'histoire
paysagère de france dont celle de sa
région le massif central en plein coeur
du pays
ici on trouve une série de volcans
unique appelé la chaîne des puys
on estime qu'on est les dépositaires
d'un des rares endroits au monde où on
peut comprendre un des mécanismes
essentiels de la tectonique qui est la
déchirure d'un continent et on a ici une
collection de plus de 80 un volcan
pratiquement toutes les formes
imaginables pour trouve dans le monde
entier elles sont réunis ici
[Musique]
si tout ce paysage témoigne d'une
histoire géologique riche et puissante
pour yves michelin il témoigne aussi de
l'évolution de la place qu'occupe
l'humain dans cet espace 200 300 ans
avant jésus-christ ce paysage là il est
déjà agricole la végétation spontanée
ici c'est la forêt s'il n'y a pas de
forêts ce qui est d'activité humaine
quand on voit de l'herbe ici derrière
l'herbe
il ya des vaches ou des moutons et
derrière les vaches et les moutons il ya
des éleveurs
si on enlève les éleveurs c'est les
arbres qui remplace est ce que la chaîne
des puys complètement boisé on le veut
ou ne veut pas est-ce que localement on
a envie de vivre dans les sapins ou pas
la réponse à ces questions s'est imposée
d'elle-même à bien des endroits en
france
allons voir la vallée de la bruche en
alsace si cette valley est une région
aujourd'hui bien forestière ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas
derrière moi on retrouve une trace du
passé industriel textile en fait c'est
une usine textile tels qu'il en existait
dans tous les villages de la vallée de
la bruche
en gros il y avait 52 sites industriels
textiles sur les 25 communes du
territoire
les gens travaillaient à l'usiné et
détenait aussi des terres qu'ils
cultivaient c'était leur mode de vie
on les appelait les ouvriers paysans
c'était une terre nourricière puisque
chacun travaillé dans l'industrie tc
mais se nourrissent et des fonds de
vallées pour de l'air pour les vaches
les coteaux pour faire des céréales des
champs de pommes de terre et les
secteurs d'un titude pour nourrir les
animaux en pâture en été c'était une
vraie économie locale qui a bien
fonctionné jusqu'en 1950 après guerre et
tout ça a péréclité de fait les ouvriers
ils ont quitté le territoire et ils ont
abandonné à leur terre quoi même s'ils
représentent un faible pourcentage de la
population française
les agriculteurs sont en grande partie
responsables de l'ouverture des paysages
s'il abandonne la terre si la friche qui
prend le dessus
mais là où l'agriculture et prospère
c'est un autre phénomène qui se produit
c'est la tendance à l'agrandissement des
parcelles les agriculteurs âgés n'ont
pas de successeur parce que le foncier
est trop cher et donc libère de la terre
qui est racheté par des agriculteurs qui
en ont les moyens et qui agrandissent
les prairies agrandissent les champs et
donc en agrandissant supprime des
supprimes des bois et donc simplifier le
paysage
[Musique]
face à un paysage qui laissent de plus
en plus place à des lieux 100 caractères
l'état français réagit depuis plus de 30
ans le pays s'est doté de certaines
politiques paysagère mais surtout
d'atlas de paysages qui ont permis de
bien caractériser le territoire et ses
paysages
ce travail il a duré dix ans pour
couvrir l'intégralité de du territoire
français et il a permis deux d'affirmer
qu' on avait une diversité de paysages
qui était absolument extraordinaire vous
traversez la france du nord au sud ou
d'est à nord-est tous les 6 km vous
changez vous changer de configuration de
physionomie paysagère qu'est ce qu'on
fait de cette diversité de cette
richesse et éviter notamment qu'on
banalise ça parce qu'on sait très bien
que les agriculteurs seront moins
nombreux pour le chercheur le rang les
lie si cette diversité dans le paysage
est l'un des fondements qui
caractérisent la culture française elle
offre aussi plus de résilience par
exemple face au changement climatique
plus un paysage et divers plus il peut
s'adapter à des crises et on le voit
bien actuellement
c'est dans les territoires qui sont
diversifiées qu'on trouve le plus de
sources de revenus à la fois pour de
l'alimentation pourra produire d
agriculture diversifiée
la vallée de la bruche a voulu retrouver
cette diversité paysagère
la région a été l'une des premières en
france à agir contre cette déprise
agricole et à mettre en place une
politique paysagère dans le but de
rouvrir les paysages c'est à dire de
remettre certains territoires en prairie
hubert tu veux continuer d'ouvrir ou
bien comment tu vois ça on a ainsi
expliqué divers acteurs locaux mis du
financement sur la table et engager des
agriculteurs à prendre part au projet et
on a ciblé les endroits ouvrir
l'opération de réouvrir ce fonds de
vallées là qui amène au village
l'objectif est de redonner des espaces
ouverts
un agriculteur comme michael rochelle
profite ainsi de certaines portions de
terrain pour 6 troupeau il contribue
aussi à entretenir le paysage pour le
bien-être de tous
ça permet de créer déjà pour les gens
qui habitent au village un milieu de vie
qui agréable c'est quand même plus
agréable de vivre dans un endroit où le
soleil passe plus facilement ou mousse
et des prairies verdoyantes que de vivre
aux abords de la forêt où ça reste
humide où le soleil ne passe pas quoi ça
crée du lien social
certains affichent dans les villages en
dix ans depuis qu'on a réouvert nos
fonds de vallées entre deux communes eh
ben on se parle parce qu'on se voit tout
simplement
aujourd'hui le paysage de la vallée de
la bruche est un peu plus ouvert
qu'avant avec plus de prairies le nombre
d'agriculteurs a doublé en 30 ans c'est
donc dire que pour réussir un tel projet
il faut y mettre le temps se fait sur un
pendant quasiment de 25 ans 30 ans et il
était possible parce qu'il ya un
engagement politique l'on regarde quand
même le point de vue qu'on a on n'a pas
regardé la carte postale de 1970 et on a
dit on veut ça c'était plus possible
puisque c'était un mode de vie bien
particulier par contre ce paysage
d'aujourd'hui ou correspond à une
agriculture d'aujourd'hui à des attentes
d'aujourd'hui par rapport à la société
le succès de ce travail a été soulignée
par tous à l'échelle française dont dans
la chaîne des puys aujourd'hui à la base
de certains volcans les pâturages
réapparaissent
on a de la chance d'avoir à notre
disposition environ 500 hectares à faire
pâturer nous mettons en commun de mines
mi-temps sur la chaîne des puys
on est quand même fier de pouvoir voir
la cime de nos montagnes de on peut pas
s'imaginer si on n'était pas là tout va
ce reboisement et ça aurait aucun
intérêt après pour personne en 2018 la
chaîne des puys a été inscrite au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
le site des volcans est protégé mais
sous une nouvelle forme
une protection naturelle mais habitait
avec son agriculture
cette espèce de deux choses absolument
impensable naturel est habitée c'est ce
que la terre est devenue avec 7 milliard
d'habitants n'y a pas d'endroits au
monde où il n'ya pas quelqu'un qui passe
est ce quelqu'un qui passe ou qui
habitent ou qu'ils utilisent
il est partie prenante de cette terre
le paysage de france attire par sa
beauté mais ce paysage peut devenir un
risque si on le tient pour acquis
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on n'a pas les moyens
d'entretenir toutes les surfaces qui
étaient entretenues quand vous aviez
beaucoup plus d'agriculteurs il ya un
siècle donc il faut s'adapter à ça si on
veut un paysage de qualité diversifiée
il faut le reconnaître en tous les cas
que les agriculteurs sont des jardiniers
de du paysage et surtout que l'entretien
soit rémunéré
[Musique]
ce que nous dit le paysage c'est quand
on regarde un petit carré d'herbe comme
celui-là ce petit carré d'herbe là il
est connecté au monde entier par les
politiques par les prix
et donc quand on va changer une
politique quand on va changer les prix
quand on va changer un accord commercial
on va changer l'apparence de cette
petite parcelle
et quand vous multipliez toutes les
parcelles vous changer le paysage de
comprendre ça nous permet aussi de faire
mieux la politique
de toute façon le paysage est un choix
et quand on ne choisit pas il n'en
arrive un autre
[Musique]
après la pause
en suisse on va jusqu'à payer pour
entretenir le paysage
[Musique]
vous que ce soit qu'on habite nos
paysages il est là il est immédiatement
là en suisse les paysages font partie
des fondements du pays
c'est une carte postale qui est là grâce
aux paysans on va jusqu'à payer pour
entretenir la beauté des lieux
c'est quand même beaucoup plus attrayant
paysage comme ça dans tout le pays si
tout le monde joue le jeu
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
c'est un chemin et qui est très très
identitaire de la grande qualité de
cette campagne l émail et de tout un tas
d'éléments qui font grande qualité dont
ces chemins de chaîne
natacha guillaumont qui enseigne à de
futurs aménagistes veut nous montrer à
quel point en suisse chaque détail dans
le paysage et réfléchie et entretenu ses
chaînes en sont un parfait exemple
ils se retrouvent le long de nombreuses
routes en dehors de genève et ils sont
protégés
cent à deux cents ans c'est exceptionnel
d'avoir des routes planté vous voyez par
exemple quand il meurt en garde les
arbres abattus parce que c'est des abris
pour tous les insectes et la micro vie
et microphone dont on a besoin et
compris la petite faune des rongeurs
donc ça c'est des corridors biologiques
ce1 d'abord qui doivent circuler avant
nous ces chaînes font partie du paysage
et on veut que ça reste comme ça
ça ne date pas d'hier que ce petit pays
où 70% du territoire et montagneux
s'intéresse à la valeur de ses paysages
au début du 20e siècle le débat sur la
protection des paysages et déjà entamé
en suisse mais il faudra attendre 1962
pour qu'on en chasse la notion de
paysage dans la constitution du pays
une première en europe on a déjà compris
à ce moment là que derrière un paysage
il y a les agriculteurs et si ça serait
de la forêt s'il n'avait pas
d'agriculture on n'aurait rien du tout
n'aurait que des forêts mais quand on
regarde le paysage ici toutes ses
terrasses c'est l'agriculteur qui l'a
fait c'est lui qui structure le paysage
aujourd'hui
regarde moi ça comme c'est beau
c'est plaisant d'invités dans un si beau
pays des gens qui viennent à moi marius
panassié est un éleveur du val d'hérens
dans le canton du valais il nous conduit
vers la halle taz une zone de pâturage
ou en montagne
ça fait plaisir tout soit faussée
entretenu sinon on aurait de la forêt
jusqu'aux portes du village
[Musique]
cet éleveur possède un troupeau de
vaches d'hérens typique de sa région
c'est les vaches laitières elle donne du
lait ont fait du fromage à raclette ici
au lait cru
un excellent fromage et puis c'est aussi
des fois ma foi on doit les tuer quand
même hein sinon on en a trop une
excellente rassasiante sa alu réveil
mais ici la vache d'hérens a aussi un
autre mandat bien particulier celui
d'entretenir le paysage c'est des
tondeuses à gazon professionnelles elles
vont partout c'est presque des chamois
et du coup tous ses alpages et toute
cette nature est entretenu et on a une
biodiversité magique et sebo mélèzes et
ses chalets qui ont des centaines
d'années que nos ancêtres ont fait c'est
notre devoir
les entretenir et de continuer à
perdurer ce qu'ils ont fait parce qu'ils
ont fait un boulot phénoménal
[Musique]
tout en bas dans la vallée du rhône
dominique bry 10 possède un vignoble
unique à flanc de montagne
cela fait partie du paysage ici depuis
très longtemps d'être les romains ont
passé dans la région la vigne est arrivé
a été cultivé par les gens de l'endroit
ces vignes s'élève en terrasse avec
comme principale caractéristique ces
grands murs de pierre on les voit
partout on reconnaît les murs comme les
châteaux
c'est les mêmes pierres c'est beaucoup
de travail pour ceux qui ont construit
avec beaucoup de temps aussi
on voit que c'est du travail fait à la
main avec beaucoup de temps et beaucoup
d'amour aussi pour le pour les faire ils
sont droit des vieux murs de qui sont là
depuis fort longtemps et qui tiennent
toujours
entretenir ses murs de pierres ou bien
faire du pâturage dans la haute montagne
est tout de même compliqué et coûteux
surtout quand c'est pour le bonheur de
nos yeux
mais les gouvernements en suisse et y
ont pensé il subventionne les
agriculteurs pour entretenir le paysage
chaque élément paysager a une valeur
différente selon le projet dans lequel
il se trouve
maturi me est l'un des gestionnaires de
ce programme
il nous donne un exemple ces arbres
fruitiers il si on se trouve dans une
région de plaine donc les beaucoup plus
facile pour l'agriculteur de supprimer
son arbre est d'arriver avec une grande
machine pour exploiter de manière assez
intensive toute la surface
l'agriculteur va recevoir de l'argent
pour l'entretien de cet arbre qui valent
de voir le taille et d'une certaine
façon il va devoir laisser de l'herbe ce
qu'on appelle une bordure tampon autour
de l'arbre une n'y aura pas de fauche
on aura une prairie un peu plus naturel
autour de l'arbre et en fonction de ça
les subsides sont calculées et plus le
travail fourni par l'agriculteur sera
important plus le subside plus là
l'aspect financier sera important aussi
[Musique]
chaque année donc la confédération
suisse des blocs près de 400 millions de
dollars pour financer divers projets
liés à la beauté des paysages au
maintien de l'alpage et à la
biodiversité
cet argent nous apporte une plus-value
pour pouvoir faire entretenir un mur
entretenir un paysage dessous tout à
fait sain pas cohérent
[Musique]
alors évidemment s'il ya plus de
paiements directs les des morceaux
entiers seraient abandonnait baquet et
les murs qu'ils y seraient bien à la
limite il et il tombera ils tomberont et
puis voilà une autre personne qui les
remettra un an et puis ce serait du
sauvage on va dire ça comme ça
deux thèmes 6 à des 1,28 à ma tête
on est à peu près je crois à 50% de
notre revenu vient de cette rétribution
alors maintenant de la mondialisation
les vaches qui broutent maintenant c'est
pas concurrentiel du tout et si on n'a
pas une aide du gouvernement mais s'en
sort montagne c'est pas possible de
maintenir une agriculture viable
en vertu des accords internationaux
la suisse ne peut subventionner
directement son agriculture
mais le pays veut développer son
autosuffisance ainsi grâce à cette aide
paysagère et de biodiversité
l'état peut soutenir ses agriculteurs on
n'a pas des immenses exploitations comme
aux états unis ou au canada
l'exploitation moyenne en suisse elle
est de trente hectares et si on va les
allées de 10 hectares donc on a assez
structure qui nous permettent de
produire à batterie et avec ses
paiements directs effectivement on leur
permet de continuer à entretenir des
terrains qui sont en pente d'avoir
toujours quand même une production
agricole à
c'est quand même important d'avoir des
paysans qui même dans le mode actuel de
production mondiale ne sont pas
rentables mais ils produisent qu'on
mange on est là pour faire ce que vous
mangez ciapa de paysans mange plus loin
pour maintenir la beauté de ses paysages
et assurer la pérennité de la
biodiversité
la suisse a choisi d'en financer
l'entretien mais avec tous les enjeux de
société
on peut se demander si c'est un luxe ou
un bien essentiel c'est vrai que si on
compare à une agriculture dans un pays
en voie de développement
c'est une politique d'un homme agricole
un peu de luxe c'est vrai on peut se le
permettre mais si on n'avait pas ça on
n'aurait plus d'agriculture en suisse
donc c'est aussi un choix qu'on a fait
[Musique]
les politiques suisses ont inspiré le
reste de l'europe depuis plus de 20 ans
la convention européenne du paysage est
un site à protéger et à prendre en
compte les paysages dans tous les
projets de développement tout ce qui est
modernité un champ éolien eu une une
usine de méthanisation du photovoltaïque
ou une maison qui une maison récente qui
se construit dans un paysage où vous
n'avez que des anciennes fermes peut
poser un objet de controverse
donc paysage a une valeur quelque part
de reconstruction du lien social du bien
commun c'est une manière de refaire un
peu de démocratie dans quel type de
paysage je veux vivre le paysage il est
tout le temps en mouvement
ça veut dire que comme il est tout le
temps en mouvement faut tout le temps
s'en occuper et tout le temps s'en
occuper ça veut dire rappeler aux élus
qu on peut pas construire partout
rappeler aux forestiers qu'on peut pas
couper les arbres n'importe comment
s'occuper du paysage est un travail de
tous les jours de tous les instants
comme respirer c'est la même chose au
québec
gerald de dôme on aimerait bien que
toutes ces idées ces politiques et ces
débats sur le paysage prennent leur
envol ici c'est sûr que non que des
besoins primaires qui sont passés avant
le paysage mais je pense quand même que
tout le monde à la fois que la santé
physique et mentale devraient avoir
accès à des paysages des cadres de vie
de qualité
et dans le contexte actuel c'est pas
normal non plus qu effectivement il ya
que les gens qui ont les moyens qu'ils
ont accès aux paysages
quand le coût des assurances devient
prohibitif un aperçu
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine à l'émission de
plus en plus d'agriculteurs ont de la
difficulté à assurer leur entreprise
quand il ne suis pas carrément un refus
certains subissent des hausses de primes
astronomiques
je comprends pas comment j'ai pu passer
du bon temps hier à celui qui m importe
l'âge je le comprends pas quand les
compagnies trouvent que la récréation a
assez duré et qu'il est temps de faire
le ménage
faut juste que ce soit un appariement
entre le risque la perte et la paix m
et c'est aussi simple que ça en 2018 on
payait ses 1200 $ d'achraf
c'est en 2020 ça coûte 80 18 mai le
dollar c'est treize fois la prime
voilà c'est tout pour cette émission au
nom de toute l'équipe merci d'être
fidèle au rendez vous et bonne semaine
verte